huh
could you use your Coke you need a
connection you can't just go ah oh
nothing happens
this is if you're striking
hey
so it comes out from within
so you've got that in your
in your store
hey now you keep it contained
you're moving quick
you cut them into your Center
katadori diet
nicchio uh
hey
what's up
happy cup
we'll try this it doesn't matter who
else
this is the Nick here I can do it this
way
here is second principle preposter Swift
it's got to be on the wrist not the
elbow
if it's on the elbow it's the sixth
principle
and he just hopes there's not a seventh
tonight
I essentially used to do ah
this movement and it was on the on the
elbow
people have interpreted it and they've
done it this way
and they go
this really hurts against the elbow this
is not really Aikido it's more jujitsu
because you're a good damage in it
you're putting the final break into it
they always say and I could oh you know
the picture shows you that he's got a
sword he comes to attack you say please
go buy you throw him down you pin him
you stick his sword in the ground you
say
calm down I've got no aggression against
you
the idea is you're supposed to walk away
I don't think in Glasgow it's quite like
that
but theory is
ah
you go this way you go the same way as
he attacks you so be careful
all right who grabbed the outside you
cut down and you just you just Walk This
Way
okay and we're trying to lock it against
the elbow
ah
done quickly
okay
well I shouldn't do it quickly if I was
you because I know the consequences of
something going more
but if you release it in any way they'll
try and come up please try and come up
you use your hand you throw a gosh
another one
if you release it at all they try and
come up
step through it's a really nice throw
you're doing this pin it's not quite
right they escape they get up
step through the hip
okay
foreign
[Applause]
that
that's it